tell Iran Obama's declines I'll stay
home with you John Legend puts on a
concert from home to entertain everyone
during coronavirus quarantine how was
nobody I was just a junior at the
University of Pennsylvania nobody knew
who I was at the time and I'm still
nobody according to Christine the live
stream included roastmaster chrissy
teigen wearing her most fashionable
towel selected by twitter.com her
wardrobe was requested by the audience
[Music]
mr. John took requests from the
Instagram live comments section one from
the offices jenna fischer with lyrics by
Chrissy
[Music]
the Vanderpump rules theme courtesy of
Andy Cohen you know these are the best
days of my life rain hi this one's for
you
[Music]
Plus new music I am gonna put out a new
album this year we're going to release
music I don't know what the schedule is
gonna be like we're just gonna start
putting stuff out
John serenaded with some fan favorites
including the song that reminds Chrissie
of the time they briefly broke up and
how she really feels about all of me
before that song got really popular I
had already been listening to it so one
of the big questions I always guys like
did you just cry whenever you saw do you
stop oh my god and she said yes of
course she does like why didn't you sing
it to me the first time you whispered
into my ear and I cried Oh
after that no it became everybody's song
which is awesome I prefer it to be
everybody's song but do I have an
emotional reaction to anymore no I don't
and that's oh hey everybody this concert
is one of many you can tune into as part
of the together at home series of online
concerts in support of the World Health
Organization's efforts to fight
coronavirus
[Music]